four day week can benefit workers  companies and Society the research shows  that people are less stressed value  their jobs more and have better lives  outside of work in most cases they are  as productive in four days as they are  in five the secret sauce is work  reorganization cutting out the least  productive activities meetings are a  prime target companies can also see  benefits through lower turnover and a  higher quality applicant pool the four  day week is a down payment on a new way  to live and work  and yes we're going to need government  help if we're going to move beyond the  Innovative companies that already see  its virtues  but as the three-day weekend spreads we  can realize everyone deserves a right to  free time